I just talked Todd Howard who's
um of the Elder Scrolls Fame and the
Fallout Fame and Beyond what's your
thoughts on Elder Scrolls why is Skyrim
the greatest RPG of all time man I
really don't like Skyrim or Fallout yeah
oh really no not at all why do you hate
Skyrim yeah so I really like characters
and like compelling stories and
narratives around those characters and I
like to see them kind of like grow and
change kind of like a movie or a story
so in your like Final Fantasy games
you've got characters
um they're a lot of like um like
classical tropes of like a character
starts off kind of like edgy angsty all
on their own they develop relationships
friendships they realize that the life
is more about themselves and they do
that and I like that that growth that's
kind of what you see in all of those old
uh role-playing games
um I didn't like the open world ones as
much because your main character is just
like a blank slate never talks it's for
you to like project onto but there's not
the same like a linear Narrative of like
growth for the camera that's fascinating
There's an actual story arc to the
character that's more crafted in a
beautiful way by the designers of the
game yeah that only one is better or
worse I tend towards like I want to hear
a compelling story around like a set of
characters that like grow and changes
again oh that's beautifully put then
yeah I I just really loved being able to
leave the town you go outside the town
and you look outside it's nature and the
world of possibilities is before you you
can do whatever the [ __ ] you want I mean
that immensity of just being lost in the
world is really immersive for me